I am SuperDuper sick can I say that yes
I'm SuperDuper excited to hang out with
three stars of the hit MTV show awkward
is that how you supposed to say it what
if we made this interview really awkward
as a cross-promotion for your show yeah
you were my dream and it's such an old
idea to make it awkward and then we have
to make it awkward we were in jams you
have this dog that I'm gonna call Eagle
food it's because you're is it
everything he wanted it to be she didn't
picture us with her on the show super
dirty yeah Eagle food Shamu go if your
dog does get eaten by an eagle I'll feel
real bad well she doesn't really go
outside unless she's in her stroller so
probably best cuz even the pigeon could
pick that thing up
I'm in Mensa it's your time you're
telling you you have you yeah you have
your mentor you guys all sync up your
menses I cozy with momentum means you
have a really high IQ yes and how's that
feel how old are you guys
yeah oh are you at the age where you
don't like talking about what age you
are cuz you look at that I've had tons
of Botox really no but the internet
thinks I have is that true yeah it's
super insulting they're like your lips
are fake oh my no you just put on lip
gloss I'm wearing lip gloss and they
don't look yeah your hair is really on
point today I thought you'd do it
yourself in the room and it was just
like whoa he does on hair you know
people throw the term fast friends
around a lot I really feel connected
your hair looks gorgeous thank you it's
acting hard easy peace learn the lines
too Sam give me the voice-over i'm doing
you yet we're gonna do voiceover okay I
didn't know who to choose Matty or Jake
it was so difficult and what the hell is
up with Sadie she's such a [ __ ] the
show is pretty sexual but we're not
allowed to hump like what what what your
face thing that you in Jesus I'm humping
on TV yeah I don't know what to do oh oh
are you guys so our show doesn't have a
theme song do you want to sing a theme
song yeah you're gonna harmonize you can
all say okay ready one two three
hee-honk show the Bo show once you're
here some of the notes only the dog
could hear
[Music]